Nó nơi vụ đang lấy kiến dự thảo như định để xuất điều trình mức lương cơ sở lên 2 phẩy năm i ba trở đồng một tháng.
Tăng khoảng tám tạm xong với hiện hành, nhóm cải thiện đời sống và tạo độ lực làm việc cho đồng mũ cán bộ,
cơm trước viên trước và lực lượng bũ trang.
Theo dự thảo, mức lương cơ sở giữa kiến tăng từ 2 phép 3 miter trở đồng một tháng lên 2 phẩy năm i ba trở đồng một tháng.
Ám dụng từ ngày 1,5 năm 2020, đây là cán cứ để tính tình lương trong các bằng lương, hủ cấp,
các chế độ cũng như các khoảng trích và mức sinh hoa phí theo quy định.
Bộ nội của trọng biết mức lương cơ sở giển hành chỉ bằng 5,5% mức lương tối theo vùng bình quân của khu cộng vấn vấn vấn nhập.
Thuyến thu nhập của cán bộ, công trước viên trước và lực lượng bũ trang còn thấp,
anh hưởng đến đời sống và hợp phỏ thông tác.
Vi vài việc đều trình là cần thiết.
Dự thảo để xuất ám dụng mức lương đối với chiến nhóm đối tượng gồm cán bộ, công trước viên trước lực lượng bũ trang.
Nguyên làm việc theo chế độ hợp đồng thu khu cơ công và mức số lối tượng khác thật quy định.
Đối với các khoảng đăng ác dụng cơ chế tại chính thương nhập đặc thù,
giữ thảo nếu gió viet bảo đam khu lạng giảm thương nhập sau với thời điểm trước khi điều trình.
Về việc đều trình mức lương cơ sở sẽ được thực hiện ngày sau khi chính phủ bảo cám của hội xem xét quy định.
Pù hợp với khả năng ngân xách, chỉ số giá tiêu dùng và tốc bộ tăng trường tình tế của đất nước.